think it's like end of the Republic like
nastiness that comes out when the
society is so you know so wealthy and so
opulent that it doesn't know what else
to do but what in investigating it what
have you seen as like Solutions or
countermeasures to I don't know teach
children other things maybe more moral
or that align more with your morals well
number one is don't send your kids to
public school so yeah that's that's all
I can say
um I think that that will help a lot and
I know it's really difficult a lot of
people it's their only option I'm really
fortunate I never I I went to private
school and I feel really grateful
um but I think that I think the root
cause of a lot of the problems we're
seeing now is public schools I agree and
I want to add to that point Ian
I was in uh Chicago Dundee Dundee
Illinois
went to a bar uh over the holidays and
there were slot machines along the back
wall and that surprised me in West
Virginia there's slot machines
everywhere you go into any bar they got
slot machines they have places they call
hot spots you walk in it's it's
literally just a room with slot machines
and it's kind of sad I'm seeing these
people who are afflicted by an opioid
crisis in West Virginia the shutting
down of their industry coal mining and
things like that so what do they do they
take their government check every month
every week and they show up and they sit
in front of a slot machine and just
press the button over and over again to
trigger that dopamine and that's that
that to me reminds me of that rat
experiment where they put the thing on
the rat's brain that when the rat would
press the button it would release
dopamine that's all it is when they go
to these slot machines but to see this
in Illinois I was like whoa because
Illinois I grew up there was always like
you can't gamble super hard to do
illegal it was only legal to have a
casino if the casino was on a Riverboat
so they have like in in Harris and
Joliet is built on water so it's legally
allowed even though it's like it's fixed
it's not really a boat but like you know
the laws then they have rivers and stuff
so there are casinos there but to now
see a regular old bar putting in a
casino putting in a slot machine
I'm just thinking like this is the end
of the Republic people have nothing left
to strive for there is no Community
there is no dopamine hit released in
someone's brain when they help their
fellow man they want to sit in front of
a machine and press the button until
they get that interested in the same
doctors and the same psychologist that
helped engineer these these people to
gamble and to to sit there and to give
all of their money or their government
check it to that that casino are the
same scientists the same doctors that
have engineered social media that have
engineered the algorithms to keep people
hooked on there and I don't know about
you but but for me personally I I do see
the the biggest groomer out there is the
algorithm is Tick Tock is what people
are being shown on on Facebook on on
YouTube but they're being recommended
what they're being conditioned and mind
controlled to believed with their
perception of reality being shaped by
these algorithms that literally uh do
make them dependent on those little
dopamine hits that incentivize a lot of
this larger debauchery and degenerate
Behavior do you think that's true or no
yeah and to add to that I I think it was
Tucker Carlson show they did a segment
and they basically investigated the
Chinese algorithm for tick tock versus
the American algorithm and it was
nothing to compare Math and Science the
yeah literally they're teach they're
they're the Chinese one is educational
and you can learn all different kinds of
interesting things and the American one
they're teaching them about pronouns and
gender identity and
all that kind of garbage and booty
shaking yeah but I will give a shout out
to the Instagram algorithm which has
been super weird because I don't know
why
but it just started showing me Billiards
videos and it actually improved my game
oh I'm excited I don't know what I'm
doing I play pool for fun and then also
I learned how to Rack a proper eight
ball game I learned like proper English
I'm not good at it or anything but I was
like oh is that how you do it I'm like I
had an idea so I'm like I'm sitting
there I'm like I'm a toilet I'm on
Instagram and I'm scrolling and then
also it shows some dude doing a curve
shot and I was like oh I didn't know you
could do that and then I'm playing and
I'm like I'm actually playing better now
like tips and tricks randomly and
algorithmically making me better at pool
don't know why I don't know maybe it's
my name yeah
they know what to they know yeah yeah
the name kind of works there too but
they know how to hook you in yeah I'm
not a pool player here's the click yeah
but they know it's gonna make me watch
right they know it's going to make you
interact with it and pay attention to it
it hears the clicking of the balls in
the Green Room when you're playing on
your phone and it's tracking it's like a
couple games a week when we're hanging
out and like we'll come downstairs we
have a pool top of your last name dude
yeah right it probably is my last name
but it recommend but here's what it does
they have that auto scroll feature you
can swipe up and it will show you random
videos Tick Tock is similar
and then what happens is it'll show you
a random video here's here's the here's
the reality there's golf videos I swipe
right past them it doesn't show me golf
videos it tried to and I ignored the
video when the billiards video popped up
I saw that and I watched the whole thing
and then it was like this guy wants to
learn more about how to play pool I see
that I scroll Tech talk a lot and I see
that a lot if I spend an extra like
three seconds on a video that I don't
want to see a random video then my whole
feed is just going to be that type of
video yeah and it's real it takes it
actually takes a few days or weeks to
get out of that algorithm and get back
to your regular it's super annoying too
I mean and and this is true for
Instagram where I'll see a video and it
like the the the thumbnail like the
graphic they use for the overlay is
misleading so I'll actually watch it and
then not knowing what it is I'll watch a
lot of it and go oh no and then you
refresh your feed and it's nothing
garbage fake videos and I'm like just
show me Jordan Clark doing triple flares
on his scooter again that's why I've
seen that video all the time I think his
name's Jordan and R Willie I love that
Nitro Circus stuff so uh Jordan Clark he
landed the triple flare recently right
that was a big deal uh I think so
basically it's a triple backflip 180 and
it was like one of the coolest things my
Instagram is nothing but skateboarding
blading scooting and BMX stuff but you
get these videos and then all of a
sudden they start dominating your feed I
have to actively go in and I'll start
scrolling through and looking for
skateboarding and then watching it
letting it play so it resets the
algorithm yeah what happens to these
kids left or right they start seeing
political content and they get sucked
into it yeah and instead of playing pool
and learning how to play pool better
people are learning how to be a victim
in society or how to be the next craze
or the next uh Trend in society that's
going to be popular and get them more
likes I I think there's a lot more to
this algorithm than we actually LED on
especially since you know there's larger
psychological studies talking about how
they could control people's emotions and
if they could control emotions they can
control a human being very effectively
face Facebook that this 10 plus years
ago I remember talking about it uh
whenever they were doing the studies on
unsuspecting users but how do you see
this do you think people are just
naturally the way they are in social
media highlights this or do you think
social media is shaping individuals to
do this
um what do you think is it the egg or
the chicken that came first definitely
social media is shaping people I think
we're in their studies or some some
something came out about Tick Tock and
their algorithm I think and I think Tick
Tock is probably the worst when it comes
to all these social media platforms I
would say because not just as not just
are they shaping people first of all
tick tock targets youth so we're talking
about young people in America not just
are they shaping them but it's the type
of content that they're doing it with
it's all of this gender identity stuff
and and all of this really making
children insecure with their identity
and it's really dangerous I'll tell you
I watch pornography from time to time
you porn shout out uh
why would you do market research Luke
I see trans videos pop up every once in
a while and I never saw that before it's
very disconcerting to see a trans person
having sex when you think there's it's a
straight couple CIS couple and then he's
got a large this is a slur unfortunately
we learn my language I guess to
assimilate with modern culture but I
mean that's another algorithm like
what's that teaching people it's
vulnerable people too
it's not just that it's it's I I
wouldn't say it's specifically trans
when it comes to the porn stuff it's any
of the weird insane stuff that's causing
kids to face to have distress there was
like there were some studies that and
look and I'll put it this way you know
we started the segment talking about
gambling as a sign of the fall of the
Republic porn absolutely is in my
opinion too now look I'm fairly
libertarian I don't care you you guys
can watch whatever you want to watch do
whatever you want to do live your life
I'm not a conservative I like
conservatives don't feel that way and
don't agree that's that's fine that's
the you know by all means but I will be
the first to stay outright there there
were studies showing that young men were
becoming they were having erectile
dysfunction with their significant
others because their brains were being
rewired by watching not like well I
don't the right word is like fantasy
porn and and impossible circumstance
porn where like 12 women are swinging on
ceiling fans and it's like orchestrated
in this ridiculous way that's not
possible for the average person so you
get these young men who are developing
fetishes watching the stuff that they
then can't be satisfied by just being
with their girlfriends and it was
resulting in ed
so this stuff I agree low birth rates so
maybe when you add all these things
together when it starts to feel like a
big conspiracy right because you've got
the castration of kids the abortion of
kids you've got people advocating for
reducing population growth on TED Talk
stages and then you've got young men
having their brains Twisted by Insane
porn free everywhere all over the
Internet with Tick Tock you're like an
expert I would imagine at this point is
it like it's owned by bite dance as far
as I know I don't think this has changed
which is basically subservient to the
CCP as are all Chinese companies at this
stage of Earth
um what do you know like when you're in
there do you feel the algorithm pushing
you and twisting you
first area no in the what into well I
searched certain things so I'm actively
seeking out the videos about about
gender and those teachers grooming case
and a lot of the the anti-white racism
stuff so I'm actually sticking that out
but they're sometimes I'll scroll
through it and I'm like how do they know
this video is exactly what I'm looking
for they they feed me exactly what I
want and then you're like I'm just gonna
repost on Twitter and then they're like
you're and then yeah they call me a
terrorist you're like hey guys someone
made this video look you're inciting
violence against them by sharing exactly
what they said yeah no I'm a little
literal terrorist they call me do you
ever feel like you gaze into the abyss
for so long that you become the demon
no that's like a niche I I I understand
the point like if you're trying to make
it even long enough but like try and
expose it I don't know if it becomes you
higher being like hey they're grooming
kids I don't think in any way has become
that much I guess a more gentle way to
ask the questions do you ever feel like
dirty like just remembering the things
you've seen does it ever it gets really
really dark sometimes yeah I can imagine
it's it's really tough It's I spend a
lot of hours looking through all this
stuff it's really dark it's really
depressing but it's so important so you
know I kind of pushed myself but there
are definitely times that I'm like I
can't I can't look at this anymore how
did you start doing this how did you
start doing this so it was during coved
um
I started noticing all these crazy
bizarre videos they were going they were
going viral
um and I was like this stuff is so crazy
I need to show more people this and I
just started posting it to Twitter and
that's really how I started there was no
plan there was no you know there I
wasn't I didn't make a business plan I
wasn't I didn't make a plan for how to
go get famous and go viral it just sort
of happened
yeah I remember like Libs I remember
when your account started getting bigger
and then I would be like I need to
follow this like this this is like an
excellent source like exposing a lot of
this what people are doing in their own
words I think it's I think it's a really
good
um it's I think more people should learn
from it and I and I have seen others
accounts sort of pop up and try to do it
too which I think is really good it's
such a it's such a good way to expose
them it's the best way actually do you
work with anyone else or did you start
it yourself or did you start yourself
and now do you work I started myself and
now I work with others so sort of around
the time when I was dogs by Taytay we
could get to that soon
um so Seth Dillon from The Babylon me he
is incredible one of the most incredible
people I've ever met and worked with he
stepped up and uh basically offered to
help me made this my career so now it's
full time
um and shout out to Seth I hope he's
watching this he's really such a great
person he's always so supportive from
the beginning always by my side always
offering to help and and all of you know
there's a lot of ups and downs in this
and he was always always there for me so
thank you Seth what does that mean he
helped helped you make it your career
because the rumor was that he bought
Libs of tick tock I I'm I don't feel
comfortable going into all the specifics
um but he yeah he basically we partnered
up
yeah well there you go yeah he's amazing
that is awesome he's been on the show
before yeah I love that guy yeah cool is
it like less work like less less
strenuous work but more fulfilling work
now do you find it's still it's still
strenuous it's
it's sometimes it's really hard there
are days when I'm like I need to take a
break I can't I can't look at this stuff
anymore and then I'll just take a day
off I haven't I haven't really taken a
vacation in a year and a half since I've
done I've taken off a day here and there
um but it's so it's just some when I
whenever I feel like you know am I even
doing anything or I'm feeling down about
the account or or the content or or you
know maybe
thinking any of those sort of things I'm
like I feel like I have a moral
obligation to continue when you see
what's out there and you see how bad it
really is I'm like how can I ever think
about stopping I can't this is too
important I completely get it I agree
you know at a certain point especially
with the company we're running I was
talking to someone recently and uh well
maybe it was Sheamus and I was
explaining like with the threats with
the swatting with all of the just as
crazy as things are he was like this is
why a lot of people would they expect
most people to just sell out Take the
Money and Run yeah you know it's like oh
you've made a bunch of money quick shut
it all down and hide but it's it's it's
I guess for me and for a lot of people
doing shows like this talking about it
was never about making money right it
was about like wow this is messed up I
gotta like I gotta talk about it you
know we gotta we gotta tell people hey
this is a bad thing yeah also I think
the higher the risk the higher the
reward so the more they come after you I
think that also
I I think that actually ends up helping
in the long run I think Ben Shapiro is a
good example right it's it's not like I
don't want to come out and say that
being harassed threat and attacked is a
good thing for anybody but so long as
you're willing to stand up people get
your back and then with all of that
negativity like when he was at DePaul
trying to speak and the cops told him
they'd arrest them those kind of moments
get more attention and help you in your
cause by shining a light on what's
Happening the injustices I mean in my
case when I was dogs I doubled my
followers literally within 24 hours yeah
we got a Times Square billboard yeah
thank you for that thank you shout out
to the Daily wire everybody give
everybody some reference with what
happened you were I can tell the story
or you can I mean from what I saw was
you were just posting content at some
point Taylor Lorenz a journalist with
him shout out to what's up Tay I do love
you as a human just so you know man um
well she's not hanging out with you
because she claims to be
immunocompromised and she was all alone
on New Year's Eve you know just you're
gonna be you're okay I mean look look I
I want to talk about that I want to talk
about the whole doxing thing and explain
how that happened and that story the
long story short just to give everybody
a primer Taylor Lorenz it was she was
with the Washington Post at the time
right she still does yeah yeah but she's
bouncing around she's like the Atlantic
New York Times published a link to an
address associated with you then they
quickly removed it and then denied
having done it like outright lied like
never did it and there were Archives of
it so I put out a tweet like they're
denying it it's crazy like we know it
happened do I need to put up a Times
Square billboard saying lit you know
Taylor's docks Libs of tick tock and
then Jeremy boring of the daily wire
said I'm down and so I hit him up we
talked and he was like bro we can we can
help make all this happen the daily wire
crew basically organized all of it and
we got a billboard in Times Square
apparently she was freaking out so
that's why I heard but what I want to
say real quick before we get into all
that
Taylor Lorenz posted a few days before
New Year's that it was like Loki the
greatest of all time to stay home on New
Year's because we're also exhausted then
posted on New Year's how awful it was
for people to be posting these party
selfies when ERS are being overloaded
and right there you could see exactly
what's going on with this with this
Taylor Lorenz this Tate I feel I felt so
bad for her because you know you know on
New Year's
I'm with my girlfriend I'm with Luke
Luke's you know we got a bunch of uh my
brothers there
and we're standing there in Times Square
at a party and the ball drop happens and
I get to kiss my girlfriend we're
surrounded by people with free food and
drinks and we're all laughing and like
yeah he's amazing and then I see her
tweets and she's like it's good to be
home alone with no friends I can't
believe people are posting videos and I
was like damn
I feel so bad for her I did kind of feel
bad too is she lashing out this way
because she's just lonely and desperate
that's what I would think yes thanks for
watching this clip from the timcast IRL
podcast hang out with us live Monday
through Friday at 8pm and become a
member over at timcast.com for
uncensored members only shows exclusive
thanks for hanging out and we'll see you
all next time